Thanks again for coming and please join
me as we give a warm welcome to Kate on.
Yo.
Thank you Tom. Thank you
everyone. Hello, fellow humans.
Wait, actually, I guess I should check
and make sure. Are there any robots here?
Any robots? I raise your hand if
you're a robot in the audience. Yeah,
I don't see any, so I think we're
safe to proceed. But you know,
I asked this question every once in a
while cause I figured one of these days
there's going to be kind of
a little spindly mechanical
arm that comes up when I
asked that question.
I'm not really sure what I'm supposed
to do at that moment if I'm supposed to
invite the robot,
come to come up here and take my job.
Because that's kind of how we talk
about robots and automation and AI and
everything these days
is like with this fear,
this dread about what it's going to
mean for human jobs, for humanity,
for kind of existential
reality as we know it.
So my premise has been to think about
how we can make technology better for
humanity,
better for our future.
And of course better for serving
business purposes. But in doing so,
I think we have to start
back from one of the square,
sort of one of the foundations.
And that is to think about
what it is that makes us human.
What is it that makes humans human?
So I'll ask you to indulge me and
just think for a moment of a word or a
characteristic that you feel like
really captures the human experience.
Like what one characteristic is it? And
I won't have you call it out or anything,
but just hold it in
your head for a moment.
What do you feel like it is
that really makes humans human?
And so let me ask,
how many of you by a show of hands
thought of something like creativity or
problem solving or innovation or
something like that? Anyone who one? Okay.
A couple people in the room. Good. Okay.
So that's a pretty common answer. Um,
how about,
this is a more common answer,
I think empathy or love or
compassion? Anyone? Yeah. Okay.
A few more hands.
Those are both great.
I think great characteristics and
admirable qualities of humans.
I didn't necessarily specify that these
needed to be uniquely human attributes.
But if you think,
if we think about those,
they don't feel like they
are uniquely human, right?
Like we've seen creativity and problem
solving and nonhuman animals like Otters,
Bang,
Mollis fun rocks to open them and Ravens
use tools and we've seen a compassion
and love from a elephants and
dogs and other other species.
So we know that those are
exhibited by other animals.
And I don't think it's too far fetched
to imagine that in the not too distant
future,
we might see at least
superficial indications of
machines exhibiting those kinds
of qualities in their behavior,
interactions with humans and maybe
even eventually everyone machines,
which will very interesting
at a surface level.
But how many of you,
when you think about what that most
human of characteristics is thought of
checking a box?
Anyone by show of hands?
Of course you didn't cause it's absurd.
But this is the sort of premise.
The problem that we encounter
in technology a lot of
the time is that we don't
necessarily think through this kind
of foundational experience and we are
presenting absurdities as if they
are sort of foundational truths. Uh,
and besides which,
if we were to try to claim that this
is a uniquely human characteristic,
we get beat out anyway by machines
can also do this characteristic.
Uh,
so I don't know how many of you have seen
this little goofy guy but he's kind of
fun.
So I have come to be known as,
as Tim mentioned,
the tech humanist and I take this,
uh,
this sort of moniker a pretty seriously
cause I feel like there is this,
this area around which technology
does have the capacity to solve human
problems.
It also has the capacity to scale.
Like we are experiencing automation
and AI and all kinds of other emerging
technologies bringing scale to
the types of solutions we create.
Like never before.
And so I think it behooves us to really
think about what the human experience
around that scale is going to be and what
the human experience around technology
is going to be.
And how we can make technology better,
solve business problems and solve
human problems at the same time.
So as I talk about being a tech humanist,
and as I think about
solving those challenges,
I'm excited that you all are in this room
and on the live stream and watching on
the video later. I hope, uh,
and then I want to offer that
perhaps that that is also you,
that you may be also our attack humanist.
And I'd like to offer that term to
you so that when you see my book, uh,
as Tim mentioned just came out
September 24th tech humanist, uh,
that you will see that title and think
I'm describing you as well because that
is the truth.
I'd like to see us all sort of join hands
in this movement to create more human
technology and more wide scale human
experiences that are more meaningful and
more integrated and more dimensional
with the technology we create.
So the premise there is how can we both
make technology better for business to
solve business challenges and make it
better for humans? Uh, and I think that,
that, that both and framing
is the key to the whole thing.
We need to understand how to,
uh,
accept that these things do
need to be integrated together.
And I would propose that the way to
accomplish this at scale is to focus on
creating more meaningful
human experiences at scale.
So how do we focus on getting
meaning into the human experiences?
So the way that that looks in the
model that I proposed is this,
on one hand,
how can we think about scaling
business meaningfully through data,
through strategic
alignment and automation?
How can we think about using the tools
at our disposal to make business more
effective while also creating more
meaningful human experiences and scaling
those through data and automation?
I've had the opportunity to test this
idea with a lot of different companies
that have consulted with,
spoken, with, advised,
worked with on different
projects over the years.
And I'm excited to say that it works in
almost every industry I've encountered.
Uh, it, it's,
it's sort of provides great results no
matter who you are or what you're trying
to accomplish. Every company is
trying to achieve profit, right?
Every company is trying to
achieve revenue based metrics in,
in what they're going about.
Even if you're a nonprofit organization,
you still have to be accountable to
some sort of profit and loss scenario.
There's some sort of breakdown of the
financials that you need to be accountable
for. And I'm happy to tell you that the
work of creating meaningful experiences
actually does lead to
increased employee retention,
decreased customer acquisition costs,
increased loyalty,
and all kinds of other directional metrics
that lead to more profit. Of course,
it's also the right thing to do.
It also creates a better
experience for all of us.
And I want everybody to be motivated
by, you know, kind of this, uh,
this aesthetic of wanting the world to
be better and creating more meaningful
experiences being its own end.
But if we have to be motivated by profit,
we can be.
And that's all a good thing too.
So let's unpack this just a little bit.
What I mean when I talk about creating
meaningful human experiences at scale,
what does that entail? So first let's
think about what meaningful really is.
So the example of the, uh, click
the box to confirm your humanity.
I mentioned,
I think that that's an absurd example
and they had this kind of running a hobby
of appreciating the tension between
meaning and absurdity in the world.
But I feel like anywhere
there is a lack of meaning,
it sort of opens up this void
into which absurdity can flow.
So where we don't create enough meaning,
where are we don't describe enough
meaning we allow absurdity to flourish.
So there's enough opportunity
for that in technology as it is.
And business really. I think you
all probably have this experience.
I'm guessing that there are areas where,
let's say you talk about work things in
ways that you wouldn't talk about with
your friends outside of work.
You use language or terminology that
your friends who don't work with you
wouldn't, would not understand, uh,
or there are things that you do at work
that just don't, that are kind of like,
that's the way we've always done it.
But anytime you think to yourself,
this doesn't make sense,
that's a really big clue because making
things make sense is what meaning does.
So we have an opportunity to step back
and assess absurdity and recognize that
that we can infuse meaning into those
structures and create more opportunity to
avoid meaning. Two, to keep
away from meaning. So the,
the reason that that works,
I believe is because humans crave meaning
more than any other characteristics.
So if you were to ask me what I think
makes humans human, this is what it is,
is that we seek meaning in,
in all areas of life.
We are compelled by meaning. If you
offer us a meaningful answer or solution,
we are compelled by it. How many of
you are a Douglas Adams fans? Anyone?
A few?
Okay,
so you already know where I'm going to
go with this in life and the hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy series.
The answer to the great question of life,
the universe and everything
was 42 of course.
So Douglas Adams wrote per
set in interviews that he
chose 42 because it was not
too high and not too low of a number.
And because it was just funny and it is,
but I don't know if you
know this, but in, in uh,
on reddit you can find this and a few
other places a collected around the web,
there are,
uh,
kind of collections of
alternate explanations for
why 42 actually kind of makes
sense as the explanation of meaning
in the world. So for example,
there are 42 characters in the phrase,
it's the answer to life,
the universe and everything. So, right.
You're convinced now, right? No. Are also,
there's like 42 dots on a pair of dice.
So that answers everything.
Uh,
which I thought was just kind
of a throwaway explanation,
but my husband said,
well, life has kind of like a roll of
the dice. So I thought, well, all right,
fair enough. Others, this,
my favorite of them is
this 42 is apparently the
unicode character can unicode
value for the asterisk character,
which as you may know,
is a wildcard symbol.
Often in computing,
which means it can mean anything,
right?
But okay,
so in the end it's obviously it just a
coincidence because Douglas Adams didn't
mean it that way.
But that's the important point is that,
uh,
even though Douglas Adams didn't mean it
that way and it is just a coincidence,
it is an absurd and poetic
and beautiful coincidence,
but we always make meaning the way
we have always done and always will,
which is by a scribing
different significance to
different events based on how
and how much we value them or in other
words, by making it up as we go along.
And I think that's the encouraging thing
about this is that even though we talk
about robots and automation and AI in
the broad mainstream in a scary way,
what this suggests is that there is
this kind of open interpretation to the
future. We get to make meaning
for the future as we go along,
we get to decide the
future as we go along.
You get to decide the
future as you go along.
And that's really incredible because
right now the, the possibilities,
the power of what's happening
within technology and
within the scale of emerging
technologies means that we
have the capacity to create
the best futures for the
most people. There's really
this Po, this potential,
and I think even an ethical responsibility
to think about how solutions can
scale to that sort of level.
So let's go back to unpacking.
Create meaningful human experiences
at scale and what is it that human
experience is really describes.
We talk a lot in business about
customer experience, user experience,
or depending on your industry and maybe
patient or gastro visitor experience of
student experience.
We don't often in many industries talk
about human experience in this integrated
way and this way that brings all of
those roles together and appreciates the
fact that there is this kind of holistic,
a human experience that that transcends
any of those roles that you are,
we are all of those roles
at any given point in time.
And so even though you may be performing
as a customer and a customer experience,
you are still a human coming
into that customer experience.
And the important thing about that is
the transcendent empathy that can come
from understanding the baggage,
the context that someone
brings to that interaction.
So there's an opportunity to create
these more dimensional interactions,
these more integrated than interactions.
And so to create more
meaningful human interactions,
it turns out we need to design
more integrated human experiences.
You'd think about how to blend all of
those roles and understandings together
and bring an understanding
of where someone has been,
where are you meeting them in the world,
and how you can create these kinds of
senses of dimension, uh, and wholesome.
So I promised a venn diagram to a friend
earlier and I have it the best venn
diagram in the entire world. I'm sure
you all have seen this. If you haven't,
you'll want to rush out and
get this tee shirt right away.
A tensile graphics
makes this Venn Diagram.
But the illustration here really I think
gets at the point then when you think
about what is possible on
one side of an equation,
such as the best technology
or the technology to make
business better and what's
possible and that other side of equation,
like what's possible to make
technology better for humans.
It's only by really thinking about the
intersection of those things that you
really come at the best
solutions like platypus.
Kutar or you don't get platypus Kitara
until you're doing some serious both
ending. So that's, that's the opportunity.
And really what we're talking about is
augmenting human experience with data and
context.
So the broader opportunity in a technology
science is to really think about
where does somewhat, where are
you meeting someone in the world?
What data do you have to understand
and appreciate where they come from,
what their preferences are,
what their tastes are,
and how can you create context that,
that addresses the objectives that you
have as a business and the objectives
they have as a human and the role that
you're meeting them in and the alignment
of those objectives. Well, how can
we come at that in a way that, uh,
that provides that?
And so I actually kind of think of this
in a way as being meaning as a service
in a sense.
And so an opportunity to think about
offering up in meaningful construct that
aligns your objective and their
objective and providing the, the uh,
the hooks in a sense to be
able to expand upon that.
And I really mean any meaning of meaning.
So meaning as we talk about
it could be at any level.
We talk about meaning as it
relates to communication.
So I'm a linguist by education, so I
think about the semantic layer, you know,
how we communicate with one another,
what we convey across our,
our communications with one another. But
it can be all the way through. You know,
you probably spend a lot of your time
if you do a lot of development or
engineering in patterns and significance,
that's probably a layer that
you spend a lot of time in.
But it could be all the way out to sort
of the existential and cosmic layer.
And what is it all about? Alfie,
you know, that sort of thing.
I think in a sense it's almost
like Api thinking for everything.
You can really sort of think about how
one idea integrates with another and how,
what does it,
what does meaningful on one side,
like the business side can be meaningful
on the human side of the equation.
How do you provide,
you know,
sorta hooks and intelligence across those
different parts of the experience and
make sure that that meaning is being
transferred through that layer.
The integration that most brought me to
this realization is thinking about how
the design of experiences online now
regularly intersects with the design of
experiences offline. But more and more
as we think about physical experiences,
they come with some sort of digital
component or some sort of trackability or
traceability with that,
that physical experience or when
we think about digital experiences,
we have to think about the physical
context somebody might be in as they
encounter those interactions.
So I wrote about this in my last book,
pixels in place.
So thinking about things like the Internet
of things and wearables and beacons
and sensors and all kinds of connected
smart devices and how are those bring
that sort of connective layer
of between those two worlds.
But the important point about that is
that just about everywhere interesting
that the physical world
and digital world connect,
that connection layer happens through us,
through humans,
through our human experience. It's
our movements. That's our behavior.
It's our patterns, it's
what we want, what we do,
what we indicate that really
creates that connection. So again,
it comes back to sort of thinking
about that integrated human experience.
So I proposed this model
in pixels in place, uh,
which is integrated
human experience design.
Thinking about how to blend those
online and offline contexts,
thinking about how to kind of come across
all the different levels and roles of
humanity that you might encounter.
Thinking about how to think about
experience in an integrated way,
interactions and transactions across
all the different touch points that you
might have.
And know it the way I'm
defining the word design,
which is the adaptive execution
of strategic intent. So you know,
you have an intention,
you have a purpose to what you're trying
to do with any given design initiative
and you know that you're going to probably
not get it exactly where you want it
to be on the first go.
So we need to build an adaptive
iterative process to this.
And the more we do this around a
framework of creating that meaningful
interaction and that
dimensional relationship between
business entity and human
that's consuming that experience,
the more we stand a chance of conveying
some sort of meaningful truth.
So the elements of integrated
human experience design
as described in pixels in
place,
I'll go through it really quickly because
what I want to get to is that with
tech humanist,
I've actually built out upon this
to a more automated understanding of
experience, but within integrated human
experience design in pixels in place,
we look at integration. Of course,
that kind of comes along for the ride.
So we're already talking about all
these layers that are being integrated,
the online and offline contexts. Uh,
we're talking about dimensionality.
So how does something come to life across
different sort of touch points or ways
in which you interact with people?
How does,
how did the metaphors and cognitive
associations come to life?
What sorts of intentional things are
you communicating through all of the
choices that you're making
about the language that you use,
the iconography you use,
and the cognitive assertions you're
bringing along with that cognitive
associations. Uh, you're bringing along
with that intentionality and purpose.
So how have you defined what it
is you're trying to accomplish?
And that comes into play at a,
at a more holistic macro level as well,
which we'll get to in just a moment
and a value and emotional load.
Like where are you meeting someone in the
world? How challenging is that context?
If you're designing for an encounter
in a hospital, for example,
it's going to be a very different type
of a valuer emotional load than if you
encounter somebody, uh, at
a, at a children's museum
where they're having fun. Uh,
hopefully having fun alignment is of
course that that sort of foundational
principle of understanding
what the business objective
is and understanding the
human objective and making sure that
they are as tightly aligned as possible.
And then adaptation and
iteration being of course,
that that process of making sure that
we are building upon what we've learned,
we're using experimentation and,
and that,
that mental model of building
our learnings as we go.
There's also this premise that experience
has a sort of to in a sense two layers
to it.
Um,
if you think about human nature
as this sort of ongoing truism,
like we all have throughout time
needed to drink water for example.
But then there's the shape
of that experience and how
it kind of gets packaged
up and dimensionalized.
And so you can see this bottle of
water a is an example of saying, well,
if I were to put that water into sort of
a heavy glass bottle and label it with
some sort of minimalistic type
face sort of brands and you know,
create that whole aesthetic and it
has this kind of hipster vibe to it.
Maybe I feel like I'm being a more
aspirational version of myself because I'm
drinking maybe even the same water out
of this cool bottle and I feel like a
better version of who I am.
Uh,
then if I just drank it out of the
tap water tap glass or whatever.
But so there's this kind of ongoing
way in which, uh, shapes evolve.
And it's important I think to recognize
that as we create these integrated
experiences that human experiences do
evolve with the shapes will always change
more readily than the nature and helps
us get into contact and sort of create
this continuity across time with the
human nature that persists throughout the
experiences that we're designing for and
yet be ready to adapt to the changing
shape of experiences. So with
that, that leads us into this,
this opportunity to think
about how machine led
experiences can actually be more
meaningful.
The more we're thinking about automated
experiences and artificially intelligent
experiences,
how can we think about making sure that
the humans that interact with those are
having as much of a sense of
meaning and significance and uh,
and dimension to those.
So what I proposed in tech humanist is,
uh, that we don't just
automate the meaning menial,
we automate the meaningful,
I'll go through each one of
these in detail of course, uh,
that we automate empathy,
that we use human data respectfully and
that we reinvest the gains in efficiency
that we get in business from automation
back into humanity and human experiences
at least at some level.
And so we'll talk about each one of these.
I'll start with this.
I think a lot of times when we
talk about automation are our,
our base understanding is that
we should automate menial,
meaningless things so that
humans can do higher order tasks,
which is a nice enough premise until you
start thinking about that at scale and
start imagining a world in which all
kinds of functions have been automated.
And most of our world is automated
and most of our interactions are with
machines and they've all been
automated to the meaningless.
So I think it's a, it's a yes
and a both and sort of scenario.
We do need to think about
automating the menial,
meaningless functions to free ourselves
up to think about higher order things.
What we also need to think
about what's working,
what are human interactions that conveys
some level of empathy and nuance that
create some sort of significance and
dimension and how can we kind of work to
automate those as well?
How can we capture some of that
significance in those automations?
So in this way, we're talking about
using data and technology to scale,
not just for efficiency,
but from meaning to think about ways
that we can actually create a sense of
dimension in the world around us.
One way that that works is I like to think
about this model of this relationship
between metaphor and metadata.
And I think the easiest
way to explain this is a,
is a slide I stole from Brian Chesky,
the CEO of Airbnb,
when he was demoing a couple of years ago,
the new campaign that they were
launching at the time, which was the,
don't go there, don't go there, live there
campaign. Anybody familiar with that?
Because we run across that at
all. So the idea was, you know,
even if it's only for one night,
go to every place you visit as
if you're a local, you know,
treat that city like you're a local.
And this slide was an illustration of
how you could experience a different type
of,
um,
of approach on TripAdvisor versus with
the airbnb approach of trusting the local
experts.
But note that extend.
So this is obviously Paris and note that
every thing on each list is different
except for one,
which was the Luxembourg garden,
which is my favorite place in
Paris. So yay me. Uh, but the, he,
each of the other things
on the TripAdvisor list,
it's really just a popularity contest,
right?
It's all just what are the most sort
of bucket list items that someone would
associate with Paris? And on
the Airbnb side, it's who has,
who has the most significant
understanding of the city of Paris?
What did they recommend as being the
places that you'd sort of must visit and
must experience in Paris?
And what I think is interesting is when
you think about the metaphor that's
really underlying this,
it's clear that the TripAdvisor metaphor
is much more about this kind of a
casual tourist experience of the world.
This kind of conventional understanding,
right? Whereas the airbnb thing is that
sort of don't go there, live there,
this knowledge of the expertise and then
the metadata clearly is it's like the
same city.
These are all the same landmarks.
They exist in either case but it's one
is being rated for popularity and one is
being ranked for this
expertise where authority.
So the way that these two sort
of dimensions interact with them,
then a creates this more
meaningful understanding of uh,
of what the company is trying to achieve
and how it brings it to dimensional
life for,
for the person that's interacting with
it because that meaning and forms the
purpose that the company is bringing
to life in their experiences and the
purpose of the company that
they're trying to bring.
The life sort of fosters the meaning that
the person is going to experience when
they interact with,
with the touch points that the group for
the company creates if they've done it
well.
And the Nice thing about this when you
think about how this really comes to life
in an automated machine led way,
is that humans really, I think when
you think about what, what the, uh,
the research shows what we most thrive
on is a sense of meaning and common goals
and a sense of fulfilling
something bigger than ourselves.
Whereas machines thrive on this
sense of clear instruction, right?
And what leads to both of
those things is purpose.
I'm not talking about perfect purpose,
like in this kind of touchy feely,
you know,
spiritual sense necessarily.
I'm talking about purpose as a set of
clear instructions or as a sense of
clarity about what it is
you're trying to achieve.
And what that does is leads
to this ability to kind of
bring all your resources
to bear in a very efficient way and
to align all those resources to set
priorities very effectively and make sure
that everybody's kind of rowing in the
same direction.
My favorite example of this,
of companies setting a strategic purpose
and really using it to operationalize
around is Disney theme
parks. Uh, and you know,
from a digital transformation
perspective than my magic band program.
How many of you then to Disney world
or one of the Disney theme parks since
they've introduced this, it
is pretty magical, right?
Like so they have articulated their
purpose statement as create magical
experiences. It's really just those
three words create magical experiences.
And so you think about
cross the organization just
about anyone in any function
can understand how they can solve problems
relative to their scope of their work
as it relates to creating more magical
experiences like a problem that's brought
to them. They can just go
along. I know how to solve this.
As long as the company actually sort of
gets in line behind that and allows them
the autonomy to solve the
problem the way they need to.
But think about that as it relates to
digital transformation and deploying $1
billion program,
which this was that investment
scale for the company.
And you can do that with complete
confidence knowing that this magic band is
going to allow people to be able to go
around the park and use it as payment,
use it as access,
uh,
use it as a sort of preferences and all
kinds of information that are tracking
that certainly gives a lot of useful
information to the company as they sort of
merchandise more effectively
and so on. But that, that,
that ability to translate the purpose
into a deployment at $1 billion scale is
very clear from,
from that that program.
So we can design experiences that are
aligned with strategic purpose so that we
could actually see that
understanding of purpose,
scale to massive levels and purpose is
the shape meaning takes in business.
So that's how we get that meaning to, to
be felt and understood at a human level.
By the way,
I keep talking about scale and so I
want to unpack that a little bit too. So
when we think about creating
meaningful experiences at scale,
normally when we talk about scale and like
a startup, we're a corporate business,
a corporate, uh, growth sort of scenario.
We are talking about like removing hard
limits so that growth opportunities can
flourish. And usually we're talking about
that in terms of multiples, let's say,
right, like three x or four x or five
x or 10 x if you're very, very lucky.
Um,
but what happens when a
notion meets nearly unlimited
expansion possibility when
data can model it and
software can accelerate it
and automation can amplify it
and culture can adopt it.
And that's what really we're talking
about with machine let experiences,
and that's why it's so important that
we think about creating these in a more
meaningful way. Because if we don't
create the meaning into the system,
what are we doing? We are allowing
absurdity to encroach, right?
And we don't want absurdity to scale.
So my favorite example of absurdity,
it's scale. It's one that I,
I don't mean to knock the program or the
product because I think it's incredible.
The Amazon ghost or how many of
you have experienced it in person.
It's pretty cool,
right?
Like the idea that you can actually
just walk into a grocery store,
you scan your app as you go in and uh,
and just pick up whatever you need and
walk right out. And there's no, you know,
sort of checking out process.
It just kind of knows it.
But through cameras and sensors and so on,
it knows what you've picked up and
what to associate with your account and
you're good to go.
So obviously we have to talk about a
cashier jobs and what that means for the
future of human work
as that goes to scale.
But let's leave that set aside for just
another moment because right now what
I'm focused on is something else.
What,
what happens when you open the APP
for the first time and you get this
onboarding that explains that as you pick
things up off the shelf, the sensors,
no.
You know what you've picked up and as you
put it into your basket or in your bag
that you'll be charged for it. So it says,
don't pick up anything for anyone else.
Okay.
Which is fine except that you start
thinking about, I don't know about you,
but I get asked all the time to help
people in stories. You seem pretty tall.
You probably get help ask for that.
Uh, you know, you get asked and,
and now it's like,
okay,
well I can't really help that person get
the thing off the shelf cause it might
charge me for it. And there's a
way to get it charged back. And,
and Amazon might fix this
before it goes to scale,
but really like 3000 Amazon go stores
have been announced before 2021 so if this
doesn't get fixed,
and if it is,
it's something that we all start adjusting
our behavior and not helping other
people in the Amazon go store.
Well that's the future of retail.
We're talking about 3000 Amazon go stores
by 2021 is going to mean that retail
environments are going to be this
cashier list environment before too long.
And so we won't help
each other in any stores.
And how long is it before we
don't help each other at all.
And I know that sounds like
hyperbole at some level,
but what I mean to suggest is that the
idea that experience at scale does change
culture.
And I that's important to recognize
because really experienced that scale is
culture.
What we sort of all collectively agreed
to do with each other and how we agree
to interact with each other is culture
and are all of the work that we do.
Creating human experiences sets that
context and creates that, that modality.
So that understanding is,
is super, super important.
So I do have a slide here and
if anybody needs these slides,
I'm happy to share them. Uh, but,
but a slide that asks questions
and it's in the book as well.
If we were to try to, uh, the program,
the absurdity of not helping each other,
we could ask some questions to
step back from that and think like,
how do we not create experience at scale?
That's going to be absurd.
How do we make sure that the brand
isn't going to be impacted if we create
products or solutions that might scale
in ways that are unexpected? How do we,
how do we pivot to deal with that?
You know, what does that look like?
So there's some questions we
can ask to anticipate that.
But primarily I think the challenges
or the opportunity is to think about
meaning and to think about
keeping absurdity from scaling.
This is a comic that was drawn from
me by my friend Rob Cottingham, uh,
to illustrate the sort of
opposite of tech humanism.
I don't know if you can read it.
It says it's getting harder and harder
to hold onto my humanity, but wow,
is it easy to track my Amazon deliveries?
So of course that's absurd,
but it's the idea that we aren't
thinking about what do we really want
meaningful experiences to look like?
What do we really want our
future humanity to look like?
How do we create technology solutions
that amplifier humanity and don't get in
the way of humanity? I think that's
really what we're talking about.
The second, uh, premise of
machine lead machine, uh,
meaningful human experiences
as to automate empathy,
which again may sound
like it's a contradiction,
but I think there's an opportunity to
think about the ways that any kind of
experience that we design creates
some kind of connection and to,
to create as meaningful
a connection as possible.
So how many of you remember the Seinfeld
episode where Kramer got a new phone
number and it was one digit off from
movie phone? Anybody remember this?
So anybody remember?
Moviefone I know the APP just sort
of ended as of like a week ago,
but um, but in the eighties
and nineties or whatever,
we all had to pick up the phone and
actually call a service to tell us what
movies were playing. And in this episode,
Cramer had gotten a new phone number.
It was one digit off or
move your phone. And, uh,
it was a obviously touch tone service.
So he couldn't understand the touchstones
that he decided that he was going to
impersonate movie phone, uh, but he
couldn't understand the touchstones.
So he ends up just saying, why don't you
just tell me what movie you want to see?
And I always find this to view such a
prescient example of how we think about
machine driven interactions and how we
think about human based interactions look
like the, the sort of
relationship between those two.
So I think of the movie phone Kramer
model as a sort of agile deployment of
emerging technology that
you can think about the uh,
the robotic interaction and the
human interaction as being somehow
interchangeable with one another so that
you can actually use human interaction
to gather patterns that you will
encode as a chat bots or other types of
automation. And not just suggest that
you would lie, that you would print,
present a human a and have
it be posing as moviefone or,
or whatever your equivalent is,
but rather that you would have some kind
of agile human based interaction that
gives you the insights to be able to
create scripts and create patterns that
develop or help you develop
frameworks for automation.
And of course you're starting
with if then statements,
but you're quickly trying to work
beyond the if then to get to the nuance.
So if that is easy to anticipate,
right?
And in the kind of a frequently
asked questions model of automation,
if you're saying like that,
if you're automating, let's
say a chat Bot for a bank,
you know that a lot of your interactions
are going to be about how to change
your password, for example, or
how to set up a new account.
So if someone wants to
create a new account,
then here's the answer and here's the,
the sort of flow diagram that
you can walk them through.
But the nuance beyond that is I need
to change my password because my ex is
stalking me.
And it's a dangerous situation and there
needs to be some human interaction.
There needs to be some human
nuance to that experience.
So that's more where the empathy gets
automated into the process is finding
those types of interactions and finding
the opportunity to build out the
relationship between the
automated and the human.
And also when we're looking for
patterns that we're not just looking for
arbitrary patterns and encoding those
arbitrary Venus is also sits in opposition
to meaningfulness in much the same way
that absurdity sets an opposition to
meaningfulness.
So we want to make sure that we're
finding meaningful patterns and automating
those. Because in all of the
work that we do with this,
we cannot leave meaning up to machines.
Machines won't do meaning.
That's just not something that
machines are really equipped for.
So it has to be humans that determine
what, what is meaningful and that,
I love this example.
I know many of you probably work around
image recognition or AI and so you know
this dilemma very, very well. It's,
I know a lot of algorithms have
advanced since this day, but you know,
the puppy versus muffin sort of a problem
is one of my faves and that it always
gets a chuckle. I see some
smiles in the audience. Uh, but,
but it's true that subtle nuances aren't
really where AI signs and many cases at
this point, at least not at a
meaningful recognition level,
not being able to say
that, uh, the muffins are,
have this certain meaningful
characteristic and the human, the puppies,
I'll have this certain
meaningful characteristic.
Whereas I believe many of you are probably
able to determine which ones a muffin
in which one's a puppy pretty well. Here's
some more. And by the way, uh, you know,
which one's a barn owl and which one's
an apple and not have any trouble with
that.
I bet which one's a croissant.
But I think this an introduces
an idea that there may be,
there may be opportunities for humans to
work alongside machines in ways that I
add nuance and empathy and understanding
to the machine lab processes,
uh, cause humans generally
do nuance pretty well.
That's something that we are encoded for.
We get meaning. That's what we're about.
So we're able to add that
into the value proposition.
So when we think about the relationship
between machines and humans,
as we move into the, the, uh,
the future of work and the
future of that sort of economy,
I think we're going to add the most
value by being human and understanding
meaning and nuance and understanding
value and understanding each other and
adding that layer to those interactions.
So the third tenant of the machine led
meaningful experiences is to use human
data respectfully.
It comes from this idea that when we
talk about digital transformation,
I kind of feel like that's a little bit
of a misnomer at some level because we
already made a digital
transformation at the moment.
We started spending all of our time in
front of screens transacting in front of,
in bits and bytes with each other.
So that's kind of a done deal.
And what's really more meaningful
than that is the data transformation.
The fact that all of this is
happening with a data layer behind it.
That business has all kinds of data,
visibility and transparency through
the supply chain, through logistics,
through operations and everything has
this kind of clarity and transparency
about what kind of trackability
is going on, what's,
what's measurable and all that.
So it's a really interesting, uh,
layer to work with. But when we
talk about digital transformation,
including automation and
digitization and all of that,
all of the many nuances of that,
fundamentally what we're talking
about is agility with data.
As companies become more digitally
writing in, digitally transformed,
are becoming more agile
with database decisions.
And that data that we're talking
about is really our data.
It's human data for the most part.
Business data is largely about people.
It's our purchases,
it's our movements through space. It's
our preferences. It's are, you know,
all of our tastes and indications
that we've made. And it really,
what I'm saying is analytics are
people, right? At some level,
for the most part, when we are looking
at graphs and reports and so on,
we're generally looking at the needs
and interests and motivations of real
people that are, they're buying from
our companies and interacting with them.
And driving all of these decisions for us.
And I think the flip side of appreciating
that and treating that data with
respect is understanding that what we
encode into machines is really about us,
that we are putting ourselves
and our biases into, into the,
the encoding, into the algorithms
and everything that we create.
So the opportunity I think as we look at
this tech humanist future is to encode
the best of ourselves,
is to think about how we can create our
most egalitarian viewpoints and our most
evolved understandings
into the data we model,
into the algorithms we build and into
the automated experiences that we design
and create.
So we can use our data,
our human data to make
more meaning in the world.
And we can recognize that the more
we create relevance, uh, in those,
in the alignment between business
objectives and cumin objectives,
the more we are creating a
form of respect. But that also,
the sort of caveat to that
is that discretion is a form
of respect to that we're
also allowing people to say,
be forgotten by us and allowing
them to take their data with them.
And that we can not make people feel like
we're creeping them out by knowing so
much about them and that we
protect human data excessively,
that we make sure we're being very,
very,
very careful with the data that we
collect and use and business decisions
because we recognize that it
is human data. The last point,
and it's a quick one because this may or
may not be within scope for many of you,
but that as we think about, uh, the,
the gains that we make in our businesses
through automation and machine led
experiences that we think
about reinvesting some of
those gains into how to
create more meaningful human
experiences at scale. Uh,
and I don't think it's really a
mystery why that's so important. Uh,
there was a study done,
a couple of versions of,
of a study done on what jobs
are potentially considered
automateable and this is
one visualization of the data
from that study that shows the,
the different cities in the
United States and how likely you,
the jobs that are there are to be
automated over the coming years.
I zoomed in on New York,
which is where I'm from,
and you see 55% of jobs are considered
potentially automate automateable and you
have to think about the socio
economic impacts of that.
You have to think about the
psychological impact of that,
that humans have had a very deeply
connected experience to work that we've
derived a lot of our sense of
meaning and identity from work.
We say who we are in terms of what we do,
and we've had names like butcher,
a baker,
a Tanner carpenter,
and so on that derived from ancestral
jobs that have been carried down through
our, through generations of our family.
And that's true across cultures.
So it's a really important thing to
understand that jobs are kind of going to
change.
There's going to be job
displacement augmentation and
replacement by automation.
And we don't yet know what
means for human meaning.
that means economically.
We don't yet know what that means,
you know, sort of socio politically.
And so there's a huge opportunity for
us to take the gains that we make an
automation and have this ethical
contribution back into society,
back to humanity and say like,
what can we do to foster a
sense of meaning and a sense
of community in a sense
of connectedness and a sense of more
humanity with that, with those games.
So I think we can also think
about repurposing human
skills and qualities into
higher value roles. So as we automate
that, uh, one of my, the executives,
it was another strategic workshop.
I led a round on utilities company in
South America and he found through our
work and opportunity to automate
a customer service function, uh,
that was their most heavily access
customer support question and function.
And once he saw that opportunity,
he saw that there was a way to take the
humans that were working in that job and
create oversight positions for them
so that they can continue training the
algorithms that we're going to,
to create that automation.
So obviously I'm very
straightforward kind of replacement.
It may not be a one for one.
We may see job loss anyway,
but some of that the investment is going
to uh, offer up human, human, higher,
higher value human roles. So here
are those uh, four tenants again.
And uh,
I think the summary of this really comes
back to as you think about the work
you're trying to do and how to create
these more meaningful experiences through
automation and through artificial
intelligence and so on,
it really comes down to this question of
what is it that you are trying to do at
scale?
So that's the purpose statement.
How can you articulate what it
is your company is trying to do,
your team is trying to do, you are
trying to do at scale. And for me,
the answer to that question is create
more meaningful human experiences.
It's just as simple as that.
But the way that I can do that is by
speaking with groups like yourself,
working with executives,
working with leaders,
and being able to help them hone in on
that purpose and really get clearer on
how to create those more meaningful
experiences that do align the business
objectives with the human objectives that
do bring the business results and that
create a better future for humanity.
So because business will have to scale
through digitization and automation,
business won't be successful longterm
without it. It's table stakes,
but humanity won't be
successful without meaning.
So in for that, I thank all of you for
the work that you do. Thank you very much.
Thanks Kate.
We have a dory.
There are no questions on it right now
so we can ask a few local questions and
if anything shows up then we'll,
we'll get those included too.
But I see a hand right here.
And can we get a mic over
here? Up The mic test, test,
test. Okay, sounds good.
Okay.
Hi. Thank you for the top. First off.
So for the rhetorical question you asked
at the very beginning of talk, I know
a lot of people, if not most
people I know would answer a soul.
What makes humans human is a soul.
So what advice would you give
about how to automate religion?
Hmm,
that's a very interesting question.
I actually have talked with a few
people about the work that they're doing
around automation and creating experiences
for people at scale around religion.
And I don't feel like I'm a in a really
good position to be an expert on that.
Uh,
it's not the work that I do,
but I do think that religion is
fundamentally offering meaning, right?
So really we're talking about the same
principles we're talking about being able
to offer people a lens into what is
meaningful and then helping to scale that.
So if,
if there is a solution that someone is
trying to build that is some sort of
technology product for,
uh,
creating like a religious experience
or a religious outlet for people or a
community. And I think it really
comes down to the same principles.
It's just like religion as
the industry in that sense.
And we're trying to offer meaning through
those experiences. I would be, uh,
probably my best to take on that,
but I think it's a,
it's a more interesting question
than that at some fundamental layer.
And it sounds like a discussion
over beers or something like that.
So do we have another, another
question? Yes. To your,
Yup. Hi. Thanks for the talk.
I was really struck by your point about
shared experiences forming culture and
um, obviously, um, we in the
technology world have a lot of,
we sh increasingly kind of
shape, shared experience. Um,
so in the Amazon go and Amazon go a point
about like people not helping you try
there.
That's something we can all probably agree
as a net negative and even Amazon I'm
sure would agree. Um, but there's
a lot of cases where we have,
uh,
the potential to shape culture where the
answer really isn't clear what is the
right thing to do.
A filter bubbles being
like one controversial idea
of whether they're a good
thing or a bad thing.
Um,
so I'm wondering what's your take on
how we should approach these problems?
Like what principles should we use in
deciding how to shape culture or what
processes are institutions maybe
we need to make these decisions.
Yeah, thank you. It's a really good
and big question. Uh, I'd like to,
to cop out and say that the entire book
tech humanist sort of addresses that,
but at some level,
um,
what it comes down to is trying to
understand that that sort of strategic
purpose, that alignment between business
objective and human objective. Uh,
and I think if you're looking at a,
at a filter bubble type of example,
for instance,
as one example of something where a,
like a social platform or um,
or an online community is fostering or
are a media company is fostering through
algorithmic content filtering and so on,
the sense of disparity between
people's collective of what is truth.
Um, I think you can probably come to
some understanding at some level of,
of view of that,
that the business objective,
which may be advertising or something
along those lines and the human objective
aren't aligned there.
So I do think that there,
there is still a useful framework there.
Um,
but I do offer some additional ones
in, in tech humanist as well. Um,
it is a really good and important question
and it's an important point for us
all I think to, to consider in
the work that we're doing. Um,
because there's so many met positives
and net goods that come out of let's say
with the social media and the
connectedness we have with each other, uh,
and the way we're able to maintain
relationships with such ease versus,
you know, 20 years ago. But of
course it does come with these,
these sort of associated,
uh,
difficulties and the challenges of making
sure that we're all sort of speaking
the same language,
which at the moment I believe were not,
we were having that question or
that discussion beforehand. Uh,
so I'm going to leave it at that.
I think there's a lot in the book,
which I'll just keep pointing
back to that, uh, that,
that does unpack that a little further.
But I genuinely think that that
framework of understanding what it is the
business is trying to accomplish and
what it is that's good for humanity,
how those things can be
in line and it doesn't,
it doesn't have to come down
to a humanitarian purpose.
It just has to mean that we're
not accelerating something
that is not ultimately
good for humanity. That that I think
is where the alignment comes back to.
Right.
There's a question on the dory and it's
sort of similar to a question that I had,
so I'm going to try to
merge them together. Um,
the question is on the dory,
it starts like this scale tends to force
humans to reduce their variety to adapt
to machines instead of the
other way around. So further,
what about ways to reduce scale that
are compatible with business? Um,
you mentioned distributism
decentralization or something
else and I'll add that.
I think that a lot of this
technological change is really coercive.
Meaning either you get with
it or you get left out,
particularly around the job changes that
you talked about and like how much is
our responsibility to bring people
along. Like to offer the lifeboat. Okay.
And how much do people really
need to get in the boat?
Yeah,
I think that's a,
that's a really difficult thing
to be able to break down in one,
one side or the other,
right?
Like I think that the change
is coming no matter what.
What we find though is the change
is going to be disproportionately,
uh,
felt.
So jobs that are most
likely to be automated,
our jobs like truck driver, cashier, um,
these types of things.
And uh,
what know is that statistically those
jobs are disproportionately how by people
of Color, uh, so that, that uh, not fair,
not equal distribution is happening.
So we,
I think we do have an obligation if we're
trying to create the best futures for
the most people,
which is what I would say is one of the
underpinning ideas or underlying ideas
of tech humanist that we have to be
thinking about how to create a more
equitable distribution of opportunity
and how to make sure that the,
the impact of automation is not going
to destroy one set of humans potential.
And while the increases the potential
for enrichment of another so that that
inequity is going to become even more
extreme than we've already experienced.
So I think it's,
it's an,
it's in our best interest as humans to
think about how to sort of shift that and
how to, how to level that out. Not
that people can't become wealthy,
but that we don't end create this even
more extreme distribution then we already
have.
So I think to some extent it's,
it's a imperative for anyone
who's creating experiences,
which is pretty much everyone that works
in technology that works around, um,
most fields that I've worked around,
healthcare, entertainment and so on.
To think about that, the, to change that's
coming and how to make sure that it is,
uh, that we are creating as much
opportunity there as possible. But yes,
I think there's also,
there's also this kind of new emerging
space around opportunities to retrain
people and repurpose, you know, get people
to understand the new skills that they,
that they might have a, they, I saw,
I shared some really great stats
in tech humanist about, um,
programs that were taking,
let's say, prisoners who were,
uh, who would come out of,
of sort of prison programs and
been able to retrain them into, uh,
into communities,
the jobs that they could keep.
And there was a 0.1% recidivism
within this program. Uh,
so I, I urge you to look
into that example. There's,
there's just so many ways that I think
an ecosystem of answers is really what's
going on here.
We have to own the responsibility as
content creators and experience creators.
And we also have to recognize that,
you know,
this is going to be a broadly
distributed, broadly felt thing, uh,
that is going to have inequitable
inequitability inequity to ways.
So to bring back a word that Paul put
in his question, decentralization,
how does maybe decentralization help
with this by spreading power around or
control around? Maybe just talk
about the centralization for a bit?
Well,
I think the idea of spreading power
runs kind of spreading control around is
interesting. I'm certainly,
we have seen, um, you know,
through user generated content, user, uh,
communities and platforms
like meetup for example.
We were talking about earlier as one way
that they're sort of tools that we can
in the hands of people that allow people
to kind of create communities amongst
themselves, create more
human connection. A,
those are going to be I
think increasingly important.
And the technologies are there to,
to sort of foster that and allowed
discovery within those communities,
allow people to sort of find, you
know, find each other and, and um,
connect more deeply.
But I think, you know,
we just have to be thinking mindfully
about the, the challenge of not,
um, you know, uh,
amplifying those sort of net negatives
as your question was alluding to earlier
with the, the filter
bubble and sign. Uh, so I,
I'd love to hear more specifically,
what about decentralization might be the,
what's sort of nagging my med,
the person's mind that's ans asking
the question or on your mind there.
Uh,
so whoever's asking that,
feel free to ask a secondary
goal and if there's any other,
or maybe for the sake of time we look
for one more question in the room before
we wrap up. Anything else? Yes.
So I have a kind of a thought
about some of this stuff, um,
in terms of, you know,
do you ever take your,
your work and look at it as a lens of
looking at humanity through the lens of
what technology is revealing about people?
Yeah,
I have looked at that,
but I'm very curious as to what is
occurring to you as you think about that.
Well, I mean, I used to do a lot of
community management and so I came out of,
um, you know, be on the bbs is back
in the late eighties, early nineties.
And so it's this kind of thing where
I realized that a lot of what happened
online was just what happened offline.
But at a different scale and
at different localities. Yeah.
And that was sort of a an Aha moment
for me when I was a part of these little
communities back in the bbs days.
So it's,
it's just kind of like as as technology
has become more and more prevalent in
our lives, it's something that
I kind of look at almost flip,
flip the conversation a little bit in my
own head of like, oh, what does it mean?
What does it say about
people given how we're using?
Yeah, that's what I mean it does kind of
a little bit of that points back to the
decentralization discussion as well. But
I liked the aspect that you brought up.
Um,
one of the aspects of this that I
have looked at is that it turns,
it seems to me that our digital selves,
that sort of aggregate set
of characteristics that
gets collected through our
movements,
through our connections,
through our interactions
in social spheres,
that digital self is really
our aspirational self.
Most mostly that we are
saying who we most want to be.
And it seems ironic to me that
that digital self is the self,
the version of ourselves that is
most commodified by business and most
capitalized upon and
manipulated by by business.
I think in our physical manifestations
we are a much less prone to that kind of
manipulation and over capitalization.
Yet this digital south, which is our
aspirational self is prone to that.
So I think this is the opportunity for
us to kind of merge that understanding
and say, well, it, it is a
human that we're looking at
in that digital, you know,
sort of, uh, collected
aggregate data points.
And so we need to be
respectful about that too.
So I think that's flipped version is
to say and others this way that we're
interacting with each other in a way that
represents who we most want to be and
who we most feel we are.
So it's all the more reason why we need
to be respectful with the data that we
collect and monetize and use
within business to inform
our intelligent decisions
in our systems.
So I'd say that that's exciting to me.
Thank you Kate. And thanks Google for
being great audience for cake. Um,
and I guess we owe us all a
round of applause. So thanks
Kate.
Especially.